i did want to thank you you're doing
something uh very cool which is i've
seen some paparazzi shots of you
i saw one where you're wearing a t-shirt
and the message on the t-shirt
says thank you frontline workers you're
using
your celebrity uh to
and the fact that there are paparazzi to
get out this great message which i
thought was
a very clever thing to do yeah we've had
a number of shirts that we've gotten
we've got uh
uh teachers aren't paid enough uh thank
you frontline workers
uh uh doctor and dr fauci we trust
so it's been a fun way to kind of
yeah no i have to say your shirts are
probably more noble than mine my shirts
have been
let's make this about me uh check out my
show
11 tbs um and i'd like to see more
evidence that this
uh covid really exists i i saw your one
shirt that says
if i'm gonna die at least let me be
drunk
conan come on man you don't need to go
to the bars
all the time well those were the shirts
i owned
before kovid and i have that was free
those are a pre-code
yeah i had a shirt that said hey man
masks aren't my thing i've had that for
years
i remember you wearing that at uh back
at nbc
yeah yeah yeah i was anti-mask way back
then so
um you're a good man i think we've been
interviewing
i've been interviewing you for i think
it's 65 years now right
we started in the old ed sullivan
theater
and uh no i was never in the ed sullivan
you're thinking of david letterman
some great great moments stupid pet
tricks
all of it so great and that was that was
david letterman
you're confusing me i've wonderful times
i i thought we were close
i've interviewed you hundreds of times
you're canadian band leader no that's
mostly
classes
so let me thank you you're thinking wait
were you thinking me or no
no no i i wasn't even thanking you
i was irritated am i getting an award
you're not getting an award okay you're
terrible
i think you're a terrible person i'm a
terrible listener
[Laughter]
hey will it is just uh always a joy to
talk to
you're one of my uh favorite people of
all time i said one of
yeah i know i know a little wiggle room
i know
you know i'm not gonna nope i know vivid
uh you're one of my favorite people i
want to make sure i get the word out
eurovision song contest the story of
fire saga
is available now on netflix and look for
will
spoken word album that will be about
18 hours long i believe coming out
sometime in the future
it's gonna be great no great awful
uh conan thanks pal stay safe and uh
we'll jam embargo one of these days
uh you didn't mean that and you'll
forget who i am shortly after you sign
off
seriously honey
a cement mixer how
what what's the confusion
the mint mixer you know what i don't
usually it's hard to build a bridge
i'm just going to do that i don't know
what are you doing i'm usually doing
single family homes but we got hired by
the city to build a bridge
and uh i don't think you're qualified to
be taking on the project
trust me i know it but don't tell the
city that